I want everyone to know that this is a
safe space here you can smoke
we won't censor you like some of the
liberals Raymond I want to start with
you there is a sense of fun and whimsy
that seems to be missing in this in this
whole political correctness moment that
we've been living in for some time well
jokes are out the door you you can't kid
and look how do we get over difficult
situations how do we overcome and find
connections with people we disagree with
we joke we make fun of each other and
ourselves that is being pushed further
and further out of society you see it in
some of the clips you played you can't
do a little racy or suggestive songs
this was a way in the 1950s that people
interacted it was a way to suggest
something without gratuitously
hitting you over the head with it now
we're in a gratuitous age where you
can't make the quiet sideswipes the fun
jokes on the side everything's got to be
very plain very black and white and
frankly it's a lot uglier out there -
it's more - thank you I'm not fun at
Jennifer this is what Jerry Seinfeld
said a few years ago he was on with Seth
Meyers talking about what it's like to
be on the comedy circuit he's also said
he will not perform on college campuses
because talk about an unfunded people
say well that's offensive to suggest
that a gay person moves their hands in a
flourishing motion you need to apologize
there's a creepy PC thing out there that
really bothers me Jennifer I don't think
it's so much about political correctness
as it is to just being sensitive of what
might really hurt someone and you know
look when we talk about you know
Christmas songs
I wouldn't necessarily put baby it's
cold outside in in the realm of
Christmas songs you know when you talk
about liberals even if it's not
criticizing you know the way played in
June the way President Trump you know
praise you know this is a president who
was sitting less than a foot away from
another president who you know a lot of
conservatives talked about being a
Muslim for the last decades as if there
was something wrong with that so I think
when we talk about turning the tide of
the national conversation into something
that's a little less offensive it
doesn't have to do with political
correctness I would
to see what conservatives would have
said had it been President Obama who did
not recite the Apostles Creed when the
entire vessel Church did one of the
things that's it's different here is
that conservatives actually try to say
we want to conserve the culture we want
to we want to conserve that what makes
us different is okay it's all kind of me
difference I can't have different points
of view but what I'm trying to get to
Jennifer and you didn't quite seem to
understand what I'm saying is that in
this world of your if you if you're
offensive if you're offended I can't say
it I can't even feel it for fear of
losing my job not getting a promotion
and not getting a you know a benefit in
the workplace people are afraid to speak
their minds that is not liberal that's
scary
and that's censorious that's what the
left always can sit could considered
conservatives Harmeet Dylan absolutely
Laura I mean you know conservatives are
not in the business of critiquing how
people pray I just think that's crass
and you know he prayed the way and he
was he felt comfortable doing and it's
not our business to critique that but
what I see on college campuses and in
workplaces where I do a lot of
litigation is that people are constantly
censoring themselves walking around on
eggshells you know young people are
actually doing consent videos before
they move to second base with a girl so
that they don't get sued and it's really
sucking all the joy out of life and I in
romance romance and if I'm an young
person these days I mean I would be I
would be like stressed out and having to
take all the drugs they take now because
they're always worried about what the
new rules are are you saying that
consent is sucking the joy out of
romance you know what I said was making
a video to document the consent is
sucking the joy out of interactions
between the sexes fear of being dragged
before board or the fear of litigation
keeps boys from asking girls out and
vice versa in some cases because they
don't know where the law is the
presumption of guilt
don't forget about title 9 which puts
all the boys who who looked at a girl in
the box for years that divided only a
conversation to be had about due process
and what we need to do on college
campuses but I think a consent is a
completely different conversation
Raymond you actually interviewed
candidate Trump talking about his faith
and going about fair in particular about
prayer but again liberals criticizing
how someone decides
to pray in the moment I it's that's wild
to me I want to play what what he said
to you about his own prayer when you
pray what do you pray for
I don't want to talk to you about that I
mean I pray it's very personal to me I'm
a person of belief but I certainly you
know I pray for my family I pay from our
country yeah but I don't want to talk to
you about that I think that's very
person okay between you and God there's
between me yes like the fact that it
wants to nobody we really don't worry
religion on your sleeve I get trash for
wearing this cross by the way over my
cold but I never get smashed for wearing
my cross I do go to my Twitter feed okay
but liberal you can do what everything
apologies through the dreary choices
ladies the moment criticizing the man
for not praying the Creed though or
reciting it first of all you're dealing
with a man who I think is new to faith
he's working his way through it and he's
not ostentatious yeah but I would
Jennifer but I would prefer someone I
would rather a faithful pagan who
follows the protects religious freedom
and advances basic morality in our
government over a pious fraud who
assaults both that's the difference that
many they feel people had with President
Obama it was the policy not the main I
think the way somebody praise and
pointing out hypocrisy in conservatives
and entices religious because liberals
have been called godless for years when
they have worship with a variety of gods
and I think if you're you know secretary
you're not arguing the point the point
is liberals claim that they're
pro-choice be who you want to be be your
authentic self my truth trump is praying
in the way he darn wants and he gets
trashed by Don Lemon I gotta be someone
I actually respected Don Lemon has gone
so far over the line god bless me I
don't know what's going on with him but
you're so obsessed with trashing Trump
that you got to trash them you know at
the moment when everyone's honoring
George Bush I don't understand that I
got it I think it speaks so poorly of
where this culture is I think it goes
back to Jennifer we people
people are truly just afraid they're
afraid they're afraid to speak trade
afraid to feel now if you if you hum
along the baby it's cold outside you
might as well have raped somebody yeah I
mean honestly it's it's gone way
overboard and it's it's just not fun
there's no fun okay can you really have
fun I guess you can smoke pot do edibles
and then talk about how you might want
to change your gender and that's kind of
interesting I guess but you can't do
much else I guess play sports what
honestly in the public life it's very
hard Jerry Seinfeld this right humor is
dead and that's why they're going a
political humor and they trash the Trump
we're moving to a secular Dogma which no
one really knows it's it's Pope Benedict
coined the phrase dictatorship of
relativism I think we're here
all right because it's only thank you so
much